welcome to this week's episode guys as
you know we're partnered with QT which
is a revolutionary social media platform
that allows people to have genuine
serious high-quality conversations about
some of the issues that we're talking
about as you'll see this week's episode
is about the housing crisis and if it's
an issue that affects you please make
sure you follow the QT link and you'd
get stuck into that discussion also as
well that we will be on there so I will
be me and I'll be personally responding
to all your comments so if you want it
don't say that they're all going to
switch off that's the point but if you
want to have a genuine discussion go on
there we will both be on there I will be
on there in particular and we'll be able
to have a chat also as well
unfortunately we are getting trolled at
the moment so if you put a comment in
the comment section on YouTube it will
be lost under a barrage of nonsense so
if you want your voice to be heard if
you want to have a genuine discussion go
on there also as well if you've got any
feedback for the show guess you want all
of that put it on the Qt and we will be
able to get back to you and as a little
teaser our guest next week is a former
far-right extremist who used to be a
member of the BNP so keep an eye out for
that on next week and we'll be talking
about that on cue tears will be lovely
to talk to Constantine's mum and we're
now spending 25 billion pounds a year on
housing benefit which is absolutely huge
it's like half of what we spend on
schools
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
guests our brilliant returning guest
this week is an economist journalist and
the author of this brilliant book home
truths which is about the housing crisis
Liam Halligan it's you welcome back to
you guys and it's been congratulations
on your success with the podcast well
it's partly thanks to you you were one
of the very few people who came on the
show initially twist my arm I did have
to put some tactics we were very kind
you came on and now we're very glad to
welcome you back you've written what I
think is a book about probably the
crucial issue of our day at the moment I
don't see a bigger issue that's a
challenge to our society in in real
terms right now the housing crisis and
I'd one of the things I didn't know
before reading the book was it's so much
worse in this country than it is around
the West which I didn't know was the
case so before we get into to talking
about it lay out the scale of the
problem for us well the scale of the
problem is that homeownership in the UK
has gone from 73 percent of households a
decade ago it's a little more than 60
percent now but within that
homeownership among twenty five to
thirty nine year olds is actually
absolutely plummeted from well over
sixty percent to well below forty
percent that crucial family forming age
at the same time today's young adults
are spending more on rent and are less
likely to own their own property than in
any decade since the 1930s which of
course was the decade of the Great
Depression and massive countrywide
indeed worldwide austerity and it's not
just that you know nice professional
people called Jonathan and Sophie can't
buy homes it's that many many other
people can't even get social housing
lower down the income scale and it's not
just a shortage of homes to buy because
we haven't been building enough it's
also a shortage of properly affordable
homes and indeed social housing
sometimes called council housing that
means we've now got a proper
homelessness epidemic massive
overcrowding in this country so-called
concealed household which I write about
in my book home truths and this
situation is more acute in the UK than
practically any other western country
the average house now costs about eight
times an annual earnings and the
elaborate earnings that's the average
across the country it's much much worse
in London than the southeast of course
but multiples are way above historic
levels in the Midlands in the northwest
and the west country even parts of the
Northeast where the economy is a little
bit slower with all respects gonna say
where no one wants to live the northeast
or East we have a big bit of banter with
our northern fans sure eight times
average earnings average multiple is up
from four times just twenty years ago
so if you're a couple and you're both
earning right you're both full-time
working you can't get a mortgage for
eight times and your learnings that's
before childcare and that is the nub of
the crisis we've got too few homes far
too few homes and that's why rents and
prices to buy are now way way beyond
earnings and you touched on the
homelessness situation I want to just
explore that a little bit you mentioned
a stat in your book that I find utterly
heartbreaking that could the charity
shelter said that it was one in every
200 people they estimate are homeless in
this country that's right that doesn't
just include homelessness on the streets
which is rough sleep it was obviously
ghastly and it's often elided with
issues to do with mental and family
breakdown and and so on it's also people
who are in temporary accommodation bed
and breakfasts and so on yeah I see look
I'm from a first-generation
homeownership family right I'm from a
working-class Irish family North London
Commons story my dad came over in the
50s managed to buy a house in the 60s
and it completely revolutionized his
view
of England he made his peace with
England gave him some stability my
parrot my mum grew up in a council house
one of 10 kids the fact that they were
able to buy a home they're not
professional people they're working
people completely transformed their life
chances and their children's life
chances and so I set out to write a book
as a kind of love letter to
homeownership and why we mustn't lose
sight of the merits of homeownership but
I ended up writing quite a lot of the
book post creme fo about social housing
about the lack of social housing and
indeed homelessness because yeah we've
built hardly any social houses basically
since the end of the 1980s the figure
plunged during the 90s under Blair and
brown we built almost no council homes
and we're only building single-digit
thousands each year now back in the 60s
70s 80s we were building 60 80 100
150,000 council houses a year and you
have to have that stock of council
housing of social housing because you're
always going to have like a fifth
something like that of the workforce you
just don't earn enough they need sub
market rents yeah it's not their own
fault they're just doing jobs that don't
command enough salary to buy a house or
rent a place on the open market
and what we've done Frances instead of
building social houses that the state
can own and give people with stability
some kind of stable tenancy we've
instead given private landlords Housing
Benefit to house those people and often
housing them in much more substandard
conditions and we're now spending 25
billion pounds a year on Housing Benefit
which is absolutely huge it's like half
of what we spend on schools well it's
really really massive rather than the
state borrowing money to build homes and
then it doesn't have to pay the and it's
got that asset on the state balance
sheet to so it net Nets neutral and they
don't have to spend all that huge amount
of money on housing benefits
in the book you outlined how you took
use of term NIMBYs not in my backyard
yeah that's the common term now yeah so
for people who saying what I don't want
but houses being built in my backyard
all the rest of it but over since 2010
the perception has changed because we
will except we're in this crisis why is
it not being something it's starting to
change
yeah NIMBYs now a well-known acronym
slightly less well known but gaining
fast as young B yes in my backyard there
are there are young B groups young B
groups that I've been in touch with all
across the UK all across many big cities
in the Western world particularly young
people who want more homes built so
they've got a chance of you know renting
somewhere decent or even better buying
their own place and getting a stake in
in a growing economy what's happened
since about 2010 is that the government
has started to give more planning
permissions local authorities have
started to give more planning
permissions to build more homes but a
lot of the big developers particularly
in the UK they act as what we call in
economics and oligopoly it's like a
monopoly of a few number of suppliers so
they deliberately go slow on building
out those planning commissions and the
fact that they hold the Planning
Commission's stop smaller firms that
build quicker getting them so prices are
kept artificially high in the face of
relentless demand in the book I call it
contrived scarcity and then the big
house builders do this they boast about
it in in opaque language in their annual
report so from their point of view old
supply the logic is if they hold on to
these planning permissions in the land
that the price of that is going to go up
so it's a no brainer for them just make
they make they make a lot more money
like speculating on land than they do on
building houses and typically if they
they can make more money building fewer
houses on a much bigger margin and the
margin for some of these big house
builders is like 25-30 percent which is
anyone in business knows it's a stonking
margin it's a sort of thing you make
when you've got a brand new technology
and you've invested in years in patents
and developing things these guys are
knocking up houses the way the
Victorians did
yeah and now it's easy it got plastic
plumbing right and so they're making
massive massive margins but look I
totally understand that for people
existing in a location in new building
there's no upside it's a lot of
disruption there's not going to be new
schools and hospitals there's not going
to be new transport facilities so it
gets more crowded of course they're
going to object and that's why of course
their house price might even suffer and
that's why the politics of planning at
the local level is so fraught but what I
argue in home truths and it's like the
centerpiece of all the proposals that
I've laid out is that when you give land
planning permission the value of that
land can go up like a hundred two
hundred five hundred fold just the
stroke of a bureaucrats pen that massive
game we call it planning uplift in most
other countries in the Western world and
particularly in Asia big parts of the
states a lot of that planning going goes
to the state particularly the local
authority so they can use that huge
value uplift to fund new schools new
hospitals new roads so people are like
yeah we'll take the houses because where
we live will get better and actually our
value of our house will go up and we'll
take the disruption of course some
people object but it's a much more
balanced conversation here in the UK we
have these very opaque mechanisms called
a section 106 and a community
infrastructure levee which are
complicated ways of saying the state
tries to claw a little bit of money back
particularly for the big house builders
but they're often rebuffed and the big
powerful house builders at the local
level say we're not going to build these
houses this year
unless you let us off these community
obligations and this amount of money we
say we would pay to four local
facilities and these happens behind
closed doors and it means that offer new
housing does not come with the public
facilities if you like the community
assets the extra infrastructure that
makes it worthwhile for existing
residents so we have to learn to share
this planning game and in home truths I
say we should share that planning games
straight down the middle 50/50 between
the local authority and the
builder / developer whoever owns the
land it's often a sort of offshore trust
by the way in this country and that
would mean that the local politics of
planning would be completely
revolutionized and the UK would start
spending as much on infrastructure you
know three three and a half percent of
GDP that many continental European
countries do in Asian countries do
rather than spending what we currently
spend one one and a half percent of GDP
because it's all out of you know
straight taxation rather than planning
game so until you make you bring up
politics and the local politics issue is
complicated I understand the point of
your making but also in the book you go
through and you give quote after quote
from politician after politician who
keep saying the housing crisis is a
crucial issue we must address it we must
tackle it and yet it doesn't it's not
happening right so why is the this lack
of political I mean one of the things
I've always thought is that in an
overinflated housing market if you're a
government that allows the housing
market to correct the people who owned
houses may well never vote for you again
right so there is that inherent problem
isn't there where the politicians have a
disincentive to actually address this
problem that's right it's said it's
you've put your finger on something very
important there and by the way I'm going
to steal this mug in the book I talk
about the Iron Triangle of vested
interests that are keeping policy where
it is so it's in a state where the big
house builders control everything and
can have contrived scarcity to keep
prices high we've massively under
supplying the demand for housing so
prices keep going up and up ahead of
earnings I don't want to see a house
price crash I want to see prices is
leveling out hmm
so earnings over a period of time can
catch up that's a completely different
scenario but the Iron Triangle invested
interest as you say and the politicians
understand this implicitly is existing
homeowners they don't want more houses
built for the reasons we've discussed
but that's starting to change as you say
social attitudes are starting to change
with people Eve
well healed people are understanding
that they're well healed well educated
children can't buy home so this is well
do you come with your money so you've
got existing home owners right there
that's starting to change your right
politicians don't want to mess with
existing homeowners because in general
the political geometry has been that
they are the majority of voters
absolutely
but as homeowners ships gone downs we
said at the beginning that's starting to
that's starting to change the second
side of the Iron Triangle vested
interests are the house builders and the
landowners right massive massive donors
particularly to the conservative party
right right that they've got a kind of
headlock on conservative half a million
quid they gave them they want is at its
massive it's absolutely massive second
only to the financial services industry
the construction industry in terms of
political donations to the Conservative
Party and then the third leg of that the
third side of that iron triangle vested
interests another massive interest group
the banks the banks are now up to their
neck in property loans now all the
building societies have become banks
been amalgamated into the banks
something like 65 percent seventy
percent of all loans in this country
extended by banks a link to property
right so the Treasury will tell every
Housing Minister oh don't mess with the
housing market because if the prices
level out or go down a little bit then
the collateral that the banks hold will
become worth less and your eleven other
banking crisis I think that's massively
overstated I think that's completely
alarmist we have such massively high
multiples of housing on earnings there's
so much increase that we've got in the
tank over the last 10-15 years that
house prices could level off and even go
down a bit and it wouldn't touch at all
the
the strength of the bank balance sheets
or threatened a crisis I think that's
completely apocalyptic so you've got
this Iron Triangle invested interests
which means that politicians want to
talk big about building more but they
don't actually change incentives to make
it happen they don't tackle this Iron
Triangle invested interests but in the
last few years something has started to
change not just those social attitudes
that Frances alluded to
what's also changed is that politicians
particularly the Tories are starting to
hear this coming up all the time even in
the Shires
and when Jeremy Corbyn came within just
a few thousand votes frankly of power in
2017 a lot of that was a surge of
support from young people and it wasn't
just people in their 20s who you sort of
expect to vote labor right if you don't
vote labour in your 20s then you're a
bastard and if you know Tory in your
thirties you're a nob did he say that he
was an educator a lot of those
first-time Corbin voters in 2017 were
first-time labour voters who gave the
Tories a hell of a scare yes may was
crapper campaign tourists but a lot of
them were into their sort of adult life
and they still hadn't been able to buy a
home generation rent and they were angry
and they're still there and they're
still angry right now in the last
election of course
Corbin took a hammering but he still did
very very well because he lost a lot of
working-class votes he still did very
very well among that kind of educated
professional labour voting class who
haven't got houses and those people are
still there they're not going to get any
less angry as they get older yeah a lot
of you know when I wrote home truths
just before Christmas it was published
I've had a lot of people writing to me
saying you're exactly right my life my
girlfriend's life my boyfriend's life
we're on hold we were in rented
accommodation we're not having kids
we're stalling and there's an
astonishing graph in the book that shows
that back in the ninth
early 90s
the average age for the woman in the UK
to have their first child was 27 right
that since gone up to 28 right but back
in the 90s at the age of 27 only 15% of
women in the UK were in rented
accommodation right now it's 40% well so
you see the point you've got a lot of
people young adults renting often when
they don't want to right yeah great
this life though one of the archetypal
sitcoms if you like Wow
dramas yeah of the 90s yeah they're all
kids in London they're renting they're
having a great time at certain times in
your life you want to rent if you're
more itinerant person you want to rent
I'm not saying there shouldn't be a
private rented sector there should be
but our private rented sector has gone
from 10 percent of households to over 20
percent of households in little more
than a decade and then you've got a lot
of youngsters locked into rental
contracts locked into a rented house
situation when actually they want to be
owning homes they're often from families
where their first generation at
University
their parents were manual workers
non-professional people with respect
their parents bought a nice house and
they can't so you've got some sort of
reversal in generational fortunes here
which tears at the social fabric I knew
everything was better than the noise
we've got an exciting new sponsor guys
it is the magazine strong words now if
you've never heard of strong words what
they do is that they review new
publications and new books now you may
not be aware of this but the UK
publishing industry releases 500 new
titles a day that is impossible to keep
up with and what strong words do is they
review the best of them that way you
don't waste time wondering what to read
next you get access to the very very
best titles exactly they're a review a
hundred books per a magazine which
they've got nine off per year if you
want to check it out we really
thoroughly recommend that head to the
website link below and enter our special
code trigger and you can get the first
issue for one pound and even you guys up
north are going to be able to afford
that absolutely an obvious
Constantin isn't into this because he
doesn't like books he believes in
burning them absolutely so if unlike me
you don't believe in burning books head
over to the website finds strong words
online enter trigger as your special
code and you can get your first edition
for one pound which is a great deal
check it out
but you believe you make this point I
think this is what I really why I think
it's such an important issue that it's
not just about economics or hardening
the impact of this kind of challenge on
society in general I mean you're talking
about demographics right demographics is
gonna be a part of this you're talking
about social cooking its effects in the
birth right now right tell us about that
mean demography is destiny right yeah it
is affecting the birth rate it's also
affecting the you know people's view of
of capitalism you know capitalism for a
lot of people isn't working if you can't
get any capital you don't like
capitalism so it does lead to more
radical politics a Society of homeowners
tends to be a more stable society as a
society a lot of academic work shows
where people are happier there's more
civic and community work you you have a
steak you know British people don't mind
other people getting rich but as long as
they have a chance and home ownership
since the second world war has allowed a
awful lot of working-class people to get
a steak to get a little bit of capital
behind them to have some life choices
right they can downsize a buy himself a
smaller place give some money to the
kids and everyone's happy if you have
this generation of 3040 now into 50 year
olds who are renting when they want to
buy what happens when they stop work
mm-hmm and they can't afford to rent hmm
where's the social housing for them I
mean the Housing Benefit bill is going
to go to the moon that's the thing about
if you have a mortgage and buy you pay
lots of money for your home but when
it's yours it's yours and then you're
living in it
rent-free and you have that asset you
have that security and now the UK home
ownership this nation of home owners is
well below the EU average and I
personally think that's a reversal of
national fortune and the current decline
in home ownership is such that we're
going to be on course to be having
owner-occupiers
as a minority of households by the end
of the 2020s
I think that's a terrible thing I think
that will completely change our national
character and indeed our politics and
Liam I mean the government have
introduced tried to introduce certain
schemes for instance to help to buy
scheme so for instance when I was a
teacher there was a lot of you know
advertisement saying you know we'll help
you get on to the housing ladder you can
get this new property and wherever it is
and it's a way for you to get to make a
step up and to make that difficult first
sleep was that a good thing now it was
it was a disaster and it is a disaster
Liam hates teachers we're gonna cut this
out no one so help to buy scheme yeah so
one of the great things about Wright
home throughs is is reaching out to an
understanding there is actually believe
it or not quite a consensus of opinion
across politics about what I've written
so on the cover of my book you'll see
praise quotes from shelter you know the
quintessential housing charity pretty
much on the left but massively respected
around the world as a sort of for their
practical help they give homeless people
but also their research expertise and
then you got Andrew Neil you've got the
Center for Policy Studies on the right
you've got you know Tory Chancellor's
praising the book other other ministers
but because there is a consensus and one
of the consensus is actually from think
tanks on the left and the right was
there helped to borrow as a bad idea and
is a bad idea because when you've got
massive pent-up demand and still
contains constrained supply if you give
people the ability to buy with even more
money funded by taxpayers prices are
just going to lap loans which is what
happened
so the margins that the big help to buy
only helps you if you buy a new build
so what help to buy did and its cost
like 20 to 30 billion so far is it just
massively increased the profits of the
big house builders who were then giving
loads of campaign donations but they
weren't didn't actually end up building
more homes the big house builders are
still building far fewer homes than they
were before the financial crisis and
we've have very few small builders now
because they were all wiped out by the
financial crisis and they haven't been
able to get a foot in the door they
can't get hold of land because the big
guys have got it all sewn up that's why
it is as I say and oligopoly some people
would say it's a cartel which is
actually illegal the big house builders
would deny that I think there is very
compelling evidence now which the big
house builders deny your honor of a
cartel in actual restrictive practices
that's why I call in the book for a full
Competition Commission inquiry at
looking at you know where we actually
examine if the market is operating
properly I don't think it is the house
Lords Economic Affairs Select Committee
the chairman Michael Forsyth read home
truths they're now doing an inquiry into
house building industry I gave evidence
to it and I and I repeated that
recommendation that we see now
Competition Commission inquiry just to
get numbers on the concentration on the
house building industries is pretty
difficult at the moment they're being
very coy about their actual output so
we'll see if the House of Lords takes up
that recommendation and what happens but
help to buy is a great for a short term
headline if you're a Chancellor and it's
good for some of the people that it
helps right but a lot of the people that
it helps and I've made documentaries for
dispatches about this have ended up in
lashed together substandard new-build
homes because the big house builders
know they're a captive audience because
they're using help to buy right and so
you end up with this situation where all
that's happened is that helped the
buyers put
stop the price of increasingly bad
quality new build homes for those who
can get access to help to buy and
they're like 95% of homebuyers who can't
get access to help to buy have to face
even more high prices and then you and
then you highlighted the bonuses that
these chairmen will get our companies
insane and it's it's in the tens of
million mind people making money again
if they've done something incredible
when brought new technology online you
know I'm a capitalist I like profit but
these are like mediocre executives
overseeing badly run companies with
ghastly customer service records I'm
looking at you persimmon and they're
using as I said technology that's been
around for you know available to anybody
you know go to a builder's yard and all
the secrets are there yeah talk to her
any number of blokes propping up bars
around the UK they tell you how to build
a house and yet they're making bonuses
of like tens of millions of pounds a
year that is a clear signal the market
is not working right
I like capitalism but capitalism needs
to work and what we got here with the
house building industry isn't capitalism
it's a grotesque Distortion that's
giving capitalism a bad name and is
working only for the firms and not for
the customers and broader society and
you mentioned the term rabbit hutch
Britain in your book can you just
explain cuz I saw again I mean it's the
lefty but I found that very upsetting
but there's this thing that you did
particularly that just blew my mind
which is councils are using thermal
drones unbelievable yeah it's [ __ ]
crazy there's two things so on the on
the rabbit hutch Britain what's happened
because because all the planning gain
all the uplift goes to share to
landowners and developers and the
shadowy opaque land agents right
it means everyone's gotten incentives is
just sit on land and do nothing right
and so land prices have gone exponential
in the face of massive demand for new
homes and that means that when a hat big
house builder does get hold of some land
it called
you know [ __ ] loads of money so the
average house that's sold in Britain now
the average new-build the land accounts
for 70% of the price back in the 50s and
60s the land would account for like five
or ten percent of the price
that's how messed up the market for land
now is that's why we need to share this
planning going to calm it down to take
the speculation out of it or some of the
speculation out of it as I say but when
you're building a house and the land is
70 percent of the price of the land
you're going to squeeze as many houses
on your building plot as you can that's
why you go to a lot of these new build
estates and I'm yeah there are good new
build house builders in this country I'm
not saying new builds are always bad but
a lot of the the more ropey end of the
market they'll be very very small the
gardens will be almost non-existent
you'll find the drive is too narrow the
garage you drive the garage car and the
garage you can't even open the doors
yeah but I've seen you British people
you don't lose your [ __ ] gara it's
always storage or a [ __ ] workshop so
you've got yes where you sleep when
you're drunk right so the houses are
very very small and we're building the
small it with building homes these days
again get to with the smallest living
rooms and the smallest bedrooms again
since the 1930s absolutely crazy
and you talk about heat-seeking drones
Constantine yes because I also write in
home truths and I go back to where I
grew up in Kingsbury North London a
pretty you know fantastic place to grow
up what massively ethnically diverse now
as it was when I was a kid a huge
privilege to grow up there and I I went
back there and I walk down the street
where I grew up and I walked around the
neighborhood and you can if poking down
the side of houses you can see so many
gardens now have sheds in them that are
clearly residential accommodation often
put up illegally and people renting
they're not paying council tax and so
what brain council did in Northwest
London and this is happening not just in
London but in suffered in Bristol
Manchester the ox
bird this beds and sheds crisis they
used in brently as heat-seeking drones
to see if people were sleeping at night
to see if people were sleeping in
outbuildings because the heat of bodies
they could see so they can actually say
to people these people live in there you
didn't put the rent on your tax return
they're not paying council tax to try
and you know curtail this illegal
activity because it's not just a tax
thing because often these outbuildings
you know electricity plumbing it's it's
medieval it's it's unhygenic it's and so
that is again is a sure sign that the
market is not working when we're
crowding residential accommodation you
know illegally into gardens in suburban
Britain that is what is now happening
and yet there's you talk to central
government about this Allah really they
have no idea they have no there's no
audit of any of this there's no grip on
the scale of this issue the Benson
chef's issue which is absolutely massive
the in Russia the way we'd solve it is
we'd put missiles on the drones but Liam
let's turn to an issue that I know a lot
of people watching this will be having
at the back of their mind right now and
you tackle it head-on in the book which
is you know people are not stupid they
do the mass and they go look we've had a
mass wave of immigration over the last
15 20 years obviously if you don't have
enough houses lots of people come
immigration cause the housing crisis you
tackle that issue I went directly I did
there's a whole sector as a whole kind
of sub chapter on that and yet you have
to tackle it head-on
the problem isn't immigration the
problem is that we haven't been building
enough houses so immigration has exposed
and made worse the problem rather than
causing the problem and in the book
there's quite a detailed a series of
paragraphs that are very closely argued
comparing the UK and France right and
over the last 20 or 30 years France has
actually had more immigration per head
than the UK France has built twice as
many houses as the UK so house prices in
France have gone up but not nearly as
wildly in front of earnings as they have
in the UK so you just need to build more
houses and then people will say oh but
we're full really if you look at the
landmass of England what percentage of
the landmass of England do you think is
taken up with residential accommodation
its 1.1 percent and that includes
gardens there is tons of space right we
haven't built a new town in this country
like Milton Keynes or willing garden
city or Harlow in my lifetime and I'm
you know I'm 50 it's completely crazy we
have had our own demography leading to
increases in population and immigration
to particularly since 2013 an accession
but the answer isn't I mean I voted
brexit as you know one reason was partly
because I accept that a big part of the
population doesn't want to stop
immigration we are a nation of
immigrants they just want to make sure
there are controls so there can be some
kind of ability to accommodate and
provide for schools hospitals and all
the rest of it so the pace of
immigration means that lifestyles on
undermine particularly for people at the
lower end of the income scale completely
fair happens in New Zealand Australia
you know Canada it's crazy
no we're we're totally on board was I
don't it's not the problem is an
immigration the problem is there's the
French example shows we just haven't
built enough houses so if you build more
houses you know we are building fewer
houses per head of population in this
country than Bulgaria right with all
respect to my Bulgarian friends were the
slowest construction rates of any
country in the EU before we left I think
with the exception of Malta means
completely mad
this is a country there's like full of
people that know about building and
people say oh where's the label well let
me tell you I'm from an Irish building
family there are a lot of people who are
plumbers who are bricklayers who are
driving cabs because in their part of
the country the building was just too
slow and the big house builders treat
them so badly so if you had some decent
house builders with access to land if
you had the sharing of planning gain if
planning permissions have to be built
out in a certain period of time or
companies were fine so it's like a
contract to build rather than an ability
to build then you could have a much much
higher rate of house building in this
country to accommodate the wave of
immigration that we've had and to
accommodate the immigrants that we will
continue to have albeit in a more
controlled environment we've got an
exciting new sponsor haven't we
constantly yes we do it is in fact the
Economist and The Economist is a
fantastic publication because it just
doesn't just deal with economics it also
deals with politics science technology
the environment if you want to read what
some of the finest journalistic minds
are writing about today then The
Economist is a publication for you yeah
I was reading an article there very
recently incredibly insightful into the
u.s. Democratic primary see if you want
that kind of insight into all kinds of
things politics economics etc I'd really
recommend it it's been a trusted source
of intelligence for people for over 170
years so they're doing something right
even when you say trusted source or
intelligence you make it sound like
these Soviets used it thanks for that a
little bit of casual racism which we now
have to cut from the ad
and there's a very very divisive issue
which you've sort of touched on which is
the green belt you know because it gets
very emotive people get very upset about
it you know building on the England's
green and pleasant land yeah look we
have in this country demarcated national
parks right no one's saying build on
them no one's saying build on areas of
outstanding natural beauty no one saying
build on you know parts of the green
belt that have aesthetic merit and
provide access to ordinary people to
exercise and get thick and and live and
get some fresh air but the green belt
isn't being concreted over and hang on
to your hats guys the green belt is now
over a hundred and forty percent bigger
by area than it was in the late
seventies because councils keep adding
to it the green belt was meant to be
around London five miles wide it's now
almost 50 miles wide in places you get
these massive commutes because people
are like jumping over the green belt
twice a day to go and live in some
rabbit hutch you know an hour a half
from London a mental health issues
anyone and family breakdown anyone and a
lot of the green belt is urban scrub
it's of absolutely no aesthetic value
whatsoever it's just like a sort of
cordon sanitaire so the be an Paul's on
don't have to have any proprietary so
let's keep some of the green belt but
let's get this in perspective the green
belt is growing and growing all the time
as councils keep adding to it because
they know it's popular because it locks
in the advantages that people have what
I'm saying is if we share planning
gained if we give more access to land to
small builders if we make planning
permissions into contracts to build
rather than permissions to build get
houses built use that planning gain to
build infrastructure then the politics
of planning changes and there'll be a
lot less local support for the NIMBYs
and to continue to lock people out
people know their kids need somewhere to
live
families are breaking up because kids
have to move you know miles and miles
and miles away from their aging parents
this is having mass
massive negative implications for
ordinary British folk and the Greenville
is one of the big issues we have to grab
and I'm glad that in the book
even the likes of Vince Cable and the
Lib Dems of you know past masters are
increasing the size of the green belts
William B central
even Vince Cable says in my book in an
interview that you can't be serious
about solving the housing crisis without
examining parts of the green belt and
giving them over to house building Liam
I just want to come back to the
immigration issue simply because I
haven't seen you know YouTube comments
and people reply yeah there's a very
simplistic way of thinking and I think
the angry people become the more
simplistic the thinking becomes so it's
very much like well we've had a lot of
immigration if you put two and two
together you get four you know but one
of the points you actually make and
before I say this as I'm someone who
very much agrees with even though I
voted remain with what you said about
correctly you know people have a right
to feel that they want to have the level
of immigration into their country that
they are comfortable with they want
people to have the tiny a positivist oh
you know 100 150 thousand every year
yeah which is but but not 350 yeah there
is a yeah I mean there's a level of
immigration that's reasonable for a
country to have and we need it yeah but
but for that to be rising more and more
is not what people want and I fully
accept that and I actually agree with
that personally but anyway my point is
one of the points you make in the book
about immigration is that actually a lot
of the people who are coming and
building the houses are actually
immigrants you know so in some ways I
just want you to address that very issue
because I know it's it's something that
a lot of people in very tokenistic
simplistic language talk about that the
housing crisis is the result of
immigration as massively exacerbated and
actually personally before I read the
book I kind of believe it yeah the
housing crisis will be the result of
immigration if we didn't have the
ability and the space to build more
houses but we clearly do and actually
house building is good for the economy
every single recovery from recession in
recorded British history
has been associated with a big increase
a big boom in house building except the
recession that followed the global
financial crisis and that recovery from
recession since the global financial
crisis has been the slowest most
lukewarm most limp recovery from
recession we've ever had partly because
we're not building homes when you build
homes you inject cash and activity into
sort of you know communities you know
people borrow locally they buy materials
locally they use local labor local DIY
local you know curtain makers and
furniture suppliers and and then you
know nannies and it creates a virtuous
circle of activity and you get big boost
to local economies when you have house
building so we clearly can build more
houses we clearly have the space to
build more houses as I said only one
point one percent of the the land mass
in England the most crowded of the four
parts of this United Kingdom has
residential housing on it and so my
family came over from Ireland and part
of part of the reason you know there was
a lot of racism around then part of the
reason the Irish were able to win the
respect of English people and I've
talked to many many people about this
much of my life it's a big theme of my
life is that English people saw Irish
people getting up in the morning working
their nuts off digging the roads
building houses yeah and that a lot of
Irish second third generation Irish
people in this country the wealth that
they have stems from that original
effort of house building so house
building is a great way for the
immigrant community to make a stand and
build them some sell wealth and respect
and acceptance for themselves and their
families and that's absolutely fabulous
so we do need some immigration and we do
need some you know bricklayers and
plumbers and and all the rest of you I'm
not saying no stop it's stone-dead but
at the same time is having some
immigration you also need to build a lot
more houses to cope because in the last
thirty years we've built something like
three million too few homes we need
roughly about 250,000 new houses a year
and the last time we built that amount
was the 80s in the 90s the 2000s and the
tens we built you know less than um you
know between one and one and a half
million so there's a huge backlog
shortage of homes which is which now the
implications of that on price and
affordability are coming to pass so yeah
let's have immigration but let's have it
controlled within those quotas let's
have people who can help us build
let's get you know our own people living
in the UK wherever they're from trained
up there's a tremendous living to be
made if there is a building more of a
building boom plastering bricklaying
plumbing and these are good trades that
a lot of people would like doing if they
had the training and if they had the
opportunity and we touched a moment on
for a little part the interview on
council housing you mentioned grenfell
and groennfell is an incredibly emotive
understandably so issue do we have a
problem now with with council housing
the cladding all the rest of it is
council housing fit for human occupation
some of the council housing in this
country is very very good it tends to be
council housing that was built in the
30s and the 50s low-rise low density
council housing the kind of council
housing that a lot of my mates grew up
in in in the suburb Kingsbury wembley
where i grew up we were all first
generation owner-occupiers or kids
living in council houses what happened
in the 60s there was a change in
legislation which meant planning game
wasn't shared and house prices went to
the moon
and councils couldn't afford to buy
enough land for low-density low-rise
council housing so they started building
tower blocks right it's absolutely
linked to this change in legislation
1961 and act that I'm trying to get
reversed as people have read the book
closely will understand that led to lots
and lots of tower blocks now Ingram fell
the issue was the cladding and we're
still in the situation as the grenfell
enquiry rolls on it must be absolutely
hellish for the families so tragically
affected you still have many many many
hundreds of tower blocks with lots of
social housing in them with the same
cladding so the cladding changing of
that to use non flammable material is
very very very slow and there's lots of
rouse about who should pay for it and
local authorities central government the
contractors and that's going to roll on
for a long time
so some council housing in this country
is very very good it tends to be the
stuff built a while ago the more modern
council housing tends to be lower
quality which is why lots of people
don't want it but I would say that we
need to distinguish Council housing we
need to accept that a lot of people do
need council housing and the government
needs to use the strength of its own
balance sheet to borrow to build that
council housing in order to offset the
massive housing benefit bill that we've
got paying for people to live in often
substandard rented accommodation when
they should be in a council house where
they can have some stability in their
own front door now there's a an
interview in there with guy called
Marvin Reece is the mayor of Bristol the
first mixed-race mayor of Europe right
of Jamaican origin he's a fabulous guy I
saw him speak at a conference and
interviewed him afterwards and he says
you know you want solve knife crime you
want to solve alienation of youth give
him a front door give him a kitchen
table he reckons his council house
literally saved his life and when he
talks about it he gets very very
emotional that's the best possible you
know an SI knife crime and C gang policy
you could have give people a front door
on a kitchen table and a little garden
you know it makes it makes a difference
and so I think we should be focusing on
council houses and some people will be
saying oh but what about right to buy
we're out right to buy now right to buy
is very popular in the 80s under
Thatcher but Thatcher stitch-up
Hazeltine
and students of politics and I'm talking
about because hesitantly put that
legislation through to make counsel you
know the right to buy for tenants he
said yes we'll do the right to buy but
the money must go back to the local
authorities so they can replace it with
another council house right now
in the end what happened was the money
four-fifths of it went back to the
Treasury had disappeared into the pot so
those council houses were not replaced
so what I'm actually calling for and
this will sound odd to some people given
that I'm a telegraph columnist I'm
calling for the right to buy now which
was reintroduced by David Cameron to be
suspended until we actually built more
Council houses the Scottish Parliament
the Welsh Assembly has already suspended
the right to buy and I think that's the
right thing to do at the moment while we
have such a shortage of council houses
it's not in England I think that should
that happen the problem is that local
authorities at the moment have no
incentive to build social housing
because if they build social housing and
people live in it for a couple of years
they then have to sell it to them at a
sub market price right often less than
the cost of building a thing given that
land prices are so high and then 4/5 of
that money that the local council gets
back that denuded amount because the
price is subsidized goes to the Treasury
so you know local authorities that look
into going through all the thickets of
admin and madness that it takes to build
some social housing it's very very
difficult it's not going to solve their
problem because the way their structures
are in Scent sense of eyes now they
could end up losing that social housing
from the public realm very very quickly
limb as we head towards the end of the
interview you mentioned that the
political landscape is gradually
changing are you optimistic that this
issue will be tackled in the next kind
of 10 to 15 years okay sort of news is
breaking around us right
so when estimate ray was appointed
Housing Minister she was the 18th
Housing Minister in 20 years and we've
just heard from the reshuffle she's been
moved so
the housing portfolio is seen as like
some ridiculous stepping stone to the
great offices of state there should be
in this in the cabinet housing secretary
and it should be a very big job with a
big political beast with big ambitions
behind it
that's what McMillan had in the 50s
that's what you had in the 20s when
Lloyd George was doing Holmes fit for
Heroes why did Lord George do Holmes fit
for Heroes and I've got some of the
cabinet minutes in my book because they
were petrified you just had the Russian
Revolution right they didn't want the
British troops coming back to the
Victorian slums they're going to be
completely radicalized they were yet
government's falling across Europe to
extremism and so to make our country
less extreme more moderate politics the
state got you know house building moving
got private house building moving got
social house building moving he actually
was a incredible guy called Christopher
Addison who was the health secretary at
the time but housing was front and
center right in the 20s housing was
front and center in the 50s housing
needs to be front and center again
because the political party that solves
this housing issue will be in power for
a very long time so Boris really needs
to get hold of this and sometimes I
think he gets it but sometimes I really
think he doesn't and Sajid Javid who
appears in my book quite a lot saying
some pretty radical things agreeing with
me on the record that planning game
should be fit split 50-50
an interview that made front-page news
when the book was published just before
Christmas we've just learnt that he's
gone now he was community secretary with
housing in his portfolio and he was
putting out policy ideas that were
really radical to try and shake up the
industry he accused publicly the big
developers of sitting on land and having
in his words a stranglehold on supply
that was in 2016 when he said that he
revolutionized the debate on housing
because stuff that I was saying suddenly
went from being conspiracy theory to
like government Paula
right in one speech and I remember when
he said it was the Tory Party conference
in in the autumn of 2016 again it was
front-page news so the big developers
will be delighted to see Javits go and I
have no idea where he went
this has literally happened while we've
been recording right and I am talk to
him I don't know hey by the time this
goes I could be Prime Minister but I do
know that a lot the big developers will
be very very glad that he is now not the
chanson inside you if you're listening
we'd love to have you on trigonometry
the fixes it will be in power for a long
time I actually think given everything
that's recently happened unless the this
recent reshuffle precipitates a complete
calamity and collapse would of the Tory
Party in terms of the broader sweep of
politics that the Conservative Party
could well be in power for for 10 or 15
years given everything that's happened
given the disastrous Labor Party and how
it's been acting lately so they have an
opportunity but that opportunity I think
is tempered by the fact that if you're a
party of the aspirational working class
which is what the conservative party now
is in terms of their electoral base yeah
you have to address this issue Oh
unbelievable otherwise people aren't
gonna feel aspirational if as you say
they don't have capital that's right
it's it's absolutely key so you know I
grew up in in Margaret Thatcher's
Britain and what was why I saw around me
you know in my own social circles as I
became sort of politicized I saw and
heard working-class people even
working-class Irish people right at the
time of the maize prison riots saying
yeah we like the Tories because there's
more work about because they've given us
a chance labour just want to keep us
down and pay us benefits and if you're
not in a union you can go hang and we're
in a similar situation now where there's
been a reversal where so-called
bootstrap working-class Tories are
coming to the fore but as Boris Johnson
rightly says they've only lent their
votes of the Tories you know
these northeastern seats these West
Midlands seats the red wall in ruins
unless the Tories grab this and make
their lives better by bringing more
prosperity to the region's better
transport links you know more housing
for kids better quality social housing
then they're going to lose that trust so
I think the Tories are on probation but
it I would you know to solve the housing
issue or address the housing issue by
building social housing by not doing
help to buy which just spots which just
pumps up the demand side but doing
supply side reforms that are hard you
got to take people on you need a lot of
administrative grits and political
courage to do it that would do far more
for the country and prosperity and the
regions and indeed for the Tories
popularity than you know hs2 or some mad
trophy asset that just makes it easier
to get to London and if you think about
you know we a lot of the housing stock
we have is actually in the wrong place
at the moment yes a housing in the
Northeast is a lot cheaper it's still
high by our historic standards in terms
of a multiple of the average wage but
it's a lot cheaper but if you have
better transport links in the Northeast
if you had you know enterprise zones
free ports you know let's scrap
corporation tax in those big
northeastern cities and watch businesses
move there watch people move theirs in a
nice part of the country to live it
fantastic you know natural places to
walk and air it's a better pace of life
for a lot of people but there's also a
lot of housing there that's relatively
well priced for young people to go and
live in if the industry and if the
enterprise was there so it's partly
about building more houses it's partly
about giving tax breaks to regions to
better use the houses that we've got and
on that note thank you so much for
coming on limb the last question we
always ask is you want to do it
constantly no I want you to do that one
of what you do it
we've bonded anyone would say one thing
we're not talking about it's a society
that we really should be well I guess in
my field of economics the one thing that
we're not talking about and I sort of
touched on it here the the phrase I'd
used is his antitrust right what is
antitrust antitrust harks back to the
likes of Teddy Roosevelt so the
Republican president at the turn of the
19th into the 20th century who forced by
journalists and he was forced by
journalists he took on the big
conglomerates the big syndicates as that
as they were then called famously the
oil baron John Rockefeller but other big
parts of the economy that had become
silted up and controlled by producers
where capitalism had stopped working for
ordinary people this was all beautifully
portrayed in Mark Twain's satirical
novel the Gilded Age and Roosevelt in
the end took on the big vested interests
and make capitalism work better got
companies to break up injected
competition capitalism doesn't happen
completely organically every now and
then it needs a kick in the shins in
order to shake it up and make sure that
competition is actually working every
now and then you need the government
with courage and a political class and a
media class to get hold of these issues
otherwise capitalism loses its
legitimacy and you get much more extreme
interventionist counterproductive
policies taking over I think we are now
entering a new Gilded Age an exact
Gilded Age it's a very pejorative term
you know Twain meant it as an insult
income inequality hasn't risen all that
much but wealth inequality has massively
increased and as ordinary people are
unable to buy homes as they don't have
pensions that wealth inequality is only
going to get worse look we still live in
a country the brexit vote showed
eventually of one
someone vote right and if we have that
policy of one person one vote in the end
we have to make sure that the system
works for a broad range of people at the
moment it's only working well it's
working very well for an ever smaller
and ever diminishing sort of gilded
elite and in order to break that you
need antitrust you need policies that
inject competition that make sure we're
on the side not of big business but of
small business on the side not of
cronyism competition that's a great
point a very important point I think you
know one of the things we talk about a
lot on this show is kind of the
emergence of woke politics I think quite
a bit of it stems from from what you're
talking about you know if people can't
have capital they can't buy a house how
do you expect them to to be capitalist
and then these extreme ideologies become
that much more appealing that's right
and I mean yeah I'm not saying a lot of
the identity politics agenda isn't
important I'm not saying that we
shouldn't be polite to each other but
when ordinary folk who are literally
trying to make ends meet here endless
television debates and endless stuff in
their newspapers about you know issues
that have no bearing on their lives they
think the political and media class is
increasingly remote from them and so
they withdraw and that's the situation
we're now in the political and media
class increasingly doesn't represent
ordinary people we've done very well in
terms of diversity of color and gender
but there's no diversity of opinion and
class I mean the equivalent of me now
wouldn't get the media opportunities
that I have managed to get in my 20s and
my 30s that's very very sad so we need
to make sure that we have a political
and particularly a media class that
actually represents and is
representative of ordinary people and if
we did have one then books like home
truths will be all over the place well
they will be after this interview make
sure you get this it's a great book very
interesting read and some really
useful I hope that all the politicians
read it first of all although many of
them already have Liam thank you so much
for coming back guys if people want to
follow you on social media and where do
they get the book of course Adam that
Liam Halligan just Google Liam Halligan
home trees you can get it on Amazon any
good any good bookshop published by bite
back out in paperback scene all right
perfect we'll see you again in a week's
time with another brilliant episode guys
take care take care and see you next
week
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word